Hôm đường bộ Việt Nam cứ định lùi thời hạn trên đổi tại khoản thu Phi sang tại khoản giá thông
đối với vời sân nghiệp và các nhân nước ngoài đến hết ngày 30,5 năm 2020.
Thế vì ngày 30,5 năm 2020.
Cứ định được đưa ra trong bối cạnh nhiều dưới nghiệp còn khó khăn khi kết nối tại khoản giá thông
với phương kiện thành tóan.
Hến vẫn còn hàng chữ chủ phương kiện sự dụt tại khoản thu Phi giá sân nghiệp đứng tên chưa thể trên đồ.
Theo công ty chứng nghiệp hiểu hạn thu Phi từ động VATC đến nay chưa có đơn vị trung ra thành tóan
trên hai vị định từ dành riêng cho dành nghiệp.
Phương án yển chi chưa đáp ứng tốc độ sử lý của hệ thông thu Phi định từ không dừng.
Thế tính dụng dành nghiệp kết nối với tại khoản giá thông chữ Phi cao từ một đến 2 phần chăm.
Một sự cao nhân đặc biệt người nước ngoài, là phương mắc khi định dành để kết nối thành khoản thông dùng viên mặt.
Cục đường bộ Việt Nam yêu cầu các nhà cùng cấp dịch vụ tiếp tục cho phép sự dụt tại khoản thu Phi hiện có để kết nối với tại khoản giá thông đến trước ngày 30,5 năm 2020.
Trong thời gian khoản thiện giải pháp.